Hey,
what's up guys?
This is Tim Ferriss and I guess you know that since you're tuning into this
feed,
this is day three.
I'm going to shave this off soon.
Had a good year of writing.
I had to take my pup,
Molly to the vet because she had a very serious laceration on her foot that
required stitches.
So general anesthesia,
which interrupted a bit of the writing since I'm working on the book,
but was able to get out of pretty decent draft of the introduction of the new
book,
which I cut down from about 6,000 words to 4,600.
So it's still a very long introduction,
15 pages,
something like that.
Uh,
so that is it
Steve.
How's Molly?
She's doing better.
She's,
uh,
she's right there.
I took the,
uh,
I took the coat off cone of shame off of her and she hasn't been fussing with
her foot.
I've,
I've covered it up.
Um,
and uh,
so far she seems to be behaving.
Uh,
all right.
Let's see.
Often the rocky,
no interaction.
Don't know who that is.
A,
can I recommend any books on public speaking?
There's a new book out by Chris Anderson About Ted,
uh,
and how people prepare for that,
which I think might be worth reading.
I haven't read it my yet,
my myself yet.
You Jason Bourne movie.
I haven't seen it.
Uh,
I have a dad bod.
Does the Geek to freak in a low carb diet or slow carb diet?
It's still work.
Yes it does.
Although I wouldn't do geek to freak and low carb,
uh,
necessarily combined all.
You certainly could.
I would do kettlebell swings and a gymnastic strength training.
So listen to my recent podcast as coach summer.
Uh,
let's see.
Am I ever involved with real estate?
Yes I am.
I've invested primarily in startups,
real estate and cash or cash,
like a quick ones.
That is,
uh,
that is my current set up.
Uh,
my take on taking modafinil.
I've tried modafinil a number of times.
Uh,
I think that it has biological cost.
It can be very tired afterwards.
At least that's been my experience.
Uh,
let's see.
Okay.
Stranger things.
I have not seen that
somebody said for fuck's sake.
Tim,
you woke me up.
If I woke you up,
then you shouldn't have notifications or push notifications on your phone
enabled.
Uh,
if I had one question I could ask myself in the mirror,
what would I ask?
Probably what would it look like if it were easy?
Whenever you're thinking about whatever you're working on,
whatever's stressing you out,
what would it look like if it were easy?
Recommend some music please.
Um,
sure.
Uh,
Brazilian singer.
Say you see you Molly millennia.
Check that out.
Uh,
okay.
Myers Briggs personality.
I have been told I'm an eye and Tga,
but I've never taken a test.
Whoever's asking about tre have no idea what that is.
Best Tips for making a successful youtube channel.
I would listen to Casey Neistat and Shay.
Carl on my podcast.
They both have whatever it is.
500 million,
2.3 billion views.
I do not.
So I'm not the right person to ask.
Hangover.
Cure your drunk right now.
Ah,
you could try Burton toast or active charcoal and uh,
definitely hydrate and get a little bit of salt.
Potassium helps eat an avocado and a drink.
Plenty of water for you.
Go to bed.
Uh,
best workout routine for an absolute beginner without equipment.
Um,
you know,
it depends on your objectives obviously I should say.
But yeah,
make a tea bar search tea bar,
which is a type of kettle bell.
It's a t bar,
kettlebell construction and uh,
for probably 10 bucks you could make something approximately and Kettlebell.
Uh,
otherwise I would say gymnastics,
strength training.
Not to sound redundant,
but there you go.
Oh,
I thought it's an aspirin.
I take baby aspirin every day,
uh,
as per recommendations from one doc that I do trust quite a bit based on my
genetic profile and the fact that my father has had a heart attack.
Yes.
Idea of cardiac disease in my family.
Favorite,
a favorite Olympic event?
Probably gymnastics at this point,
although I do love some funny ones.
I mean I enjoy boxing figure skating,
tennis is tennis,
more big sport.
I do enjoy watching tennis though.
Um,
sensory deprivation tanks.
Yes.
I have tried a DNA angle,
talks about it quite a bit in the podcast I do with him.
I'm going to do a couple more and then I'm going to bed guys,
cause it's been a very long day.
Do I use essential oils?
Believe it or not.
I do.
This is recent.
This is a,
I just started after my podcast with Nicholas McCarthy.
So you can actually see that I have an essential oil diffuser right there.
And I've been using Geranium,
which is what Nicholas McCarthy uses.
Let's see,
what the fuck is tre?
Transcendental meditation tree.
I have no idea what that is.
Trembling maybe if that,
if that's your question.
I'm not using Trimble out.
Uh,
caffeine and lt and Ian,
if I combine those I get,
I actually feel agitated so I don't do it.
Uh,
is it worth booking up?
Eating an extra thousand calories a day,
decreases your lifespan?
That's a personal question up to you to decide.
A neat,
you're welcome for the younger interview.
He's amazing.
What do I think ty Lopez don't know anything about them?
So I don't have an opinion.
Uh,
let's see.
Kyoto,
Kyoto and then,
so one thing I believe to be the most critical and doing public presentations,
knowing your strengths.
So I know that I'm not the most flamboyant or compelling performer,
so to speak as a speaker.
So I focused on teaching and I'm very upfront with that.
I said I'm not going to be the most exciting speaker to watch,
but I'll try to throw it a little bit of Hebrew,
but more than anything else,
I will try to give you more actionable takeaways in the next 30 minutes than
I've ever given before.
And really focus on specific action.
We'll take away.
Uh,
I always break my presentations into three sections are typically into three
sections and you can actually Google how I prepare for public speaking.
So how Tim Ferriss or Tim Ferriss,
how I prepare for public speaking every time,
something like that.
And you'll get a whole list.
Uh,
all rights
guys,
I'm going to go to bed,
it's late and I have some people in my house that I need to attend to.
So I'm going to let you get going.
And since this is a supposed to be a daily Vlog,
we'll fuck.
I guess I'll be seeing you guys tomorrow.
Have a good one.
Good night.
Thanks so much for watching guys and be sure to consider signing up for my email
newsletter by clicking on email and newsletter because I share private Q and A's
exclusive content.
Awesome things like five bullet Fridays,
which is the five coolest things I've discovered in a given week exclusively via
email.
And that's for the diehard,
that's for the people who really want the main line of usefulness and how to and
uh,
to really ride along with me as I learn and discover the most useful things that
I find.
So check it out,
email newsletter,
click on it,
and please let me know what you would like more of in terms of video,
in terms of audio.
I will try to make it for you.
So let me know in the comments and thank you again for watching.